es el siguiente círculo representa la unidad
Creo que aquí tenemos este círculo.
representa una unidad y como
lo que sabemos es que no podemos responder a la
siguiente si fracciones de círculo es
perseguido por el azul y con eso termina con
queremos saber que la acción es
bin embrujada
el primero vamos a ser b este entero
que tengo aquí notas 31 se divide
en tres partes se divide en diez
juegos en tres partes iguales y cada uno en el
df las piezas cada noreste las piernas
que tengo aquí observa que es lo mismo que el
nombre de este ostensible una prueba en un
de estas tres partes iguales
ganar el trabajo que sabemos y podemos querer
esta imagen de boton y veremos cuantos
pedazos de una prueba tenemos un pedazo de
un tercio por aquí tenemos otra pieza de
ayer en saotorcato tenemos otra pieza
de un tercero
otra pieza de un tercio y aquí está
la última pieza de una tesis cada
los restos están embrujados azules
tenemos dos tres cuatro cinco piezas uno
prueba
mira el mismo queso que 5 tienen sus
cinco potencias sombreadas 10o